ah
el camino y nuestra vista mi retro bay
pero una selva oscura que la directa
vieras marita estos los comienzos más
célebres y mejores de la literatura
universal y así arrancaba dante su
divina comedia' el año que viene va a
ser 700 años de esto aquí tenéis la
traducción a mitad del viaje en nuestra
vida me encontré en un bosque oscuro
pues el camino derecho había perdido
y dante que es lo que hace aquí en dan
te habla del viaje de la vida de la vida
con viaje en cuya mitad se pierde y
además unos versos más adelante dice no
es que me quedé dormido no me acuerdo
exactamente del punto donde me perdí
porque porque estaba dormido y si si os
fijáis y lo pensáis esto es como una
plantilla de cómo son las pelis de
terror un tío va en coche se despista se
sale de la autopista repente está en un
lugar truculento se ha perdido y
espérate que hay una hay más en este
caso se mira en el retrovisor y tiene 40
palos allá no es joven es el año de la
juventud bueno pues sí de los 14 mil 233
versos que tiene la adivina como ella
sólo queda este terceto habría pasado la
historia como la primera definición de
la crisis de los 40 años
vamos a ver aquí tenemos adelante hay
perdido en el bosque
y bueno pues a ese bosque
ese bosque oscuro algunos habréis estado
ya estaréis otros vais a llegar otros
habréis salido que es el bosque oscuro
este que hay a mitad del viaje la vida
bueno pues el bosque oscuro es cuando
cuando el domingo por la tarde dices
cómo tengo que ir al trabajo al día
siguiente odio a mi jefe no me interesa
nada lo que hago el bosque descubres
cuando tres chándal espantoso en la
cinta y parece como que eres un hámster
de agua aquí es cuando te despiertas y
ves a alguien roncando a tu lado la cama
te resulte reconocible y es tu pareja y
es también cuando cuando bueno cuando
piensas como yo todos los talentos que
yo tenía y no he hecho nada con ellos y
ya se me pase no va a encontrar ningún
lugar para implementarlos
y en definitiva un bosque que es un
sitio lleno de árboles y de ruidos y de
bichos y de piedras edad
el bosque el bosque oscuro está vacío no
hay nada es es el vacío existencial es
es la pérdida del sentido por la pérdida
ese camino es la pérdida del sentido de
la vida y seguramente habréis escuchado
la gente confesados sino que nos habéis
dicho vosotros a vosotros mismos esta no
es la vida que yo quería si vuestra
pareja lo dice mucho pues pues preocupar
pero está en el área que yo soy muy
preguntó de vida querías no esperéis que
la gente lo tiene claro shazam en la
vida que no querían se pone a pensar la
vida que sabía que hubieran querido que
ella sí pues no yo quería haber
estudiado algo más creativo o quería
haber vivido en el extranjero o dos años
o haberme caso más tarde o haber tenido
hijos antes y en realidad están poniendo
ahí todo el foco en los trenes que han
perdido las decisiones que han tomado en
todo aquello que les ha conducido a ese
bosque oscuro donde están atrapadas
y cómo se sale del bosque oscuro claro
bueno no sé si te pones a fijarte en lo
que no has hecho y en lo que ya no te da
tiempo a hacer ya se ha pasado y no está
en vivo es eso te va a conducir a la
melancolía o por lo menos yo cuando yo
estoy el bosque oscuro que me fijé las
pistas las señales las encontré dentro
de mí entre cosas que ya ya había hecho
entonces los voy a llevar un poco a mi
bosque oscuro
hay en la vida cuatro circunstancias de
las que probablemente no os vais a
librar y que normalmente uno se suele
encontrar en el medio del camino del
viaje de la vida
especialmente traumáticas y que vacían
de sentido la vida como ninguna otra
cosa una es la muerte un ser querido
otra es una separación amorosa otra es
perder vuestro trabajo vuestro empleo o
vuestro proyecto laboral y en la cuarta
es una mudanza
iros un abogado es terrible
yo en 2016 en primarias yo cumplí 40
años en mi vida concurrían tres de estas
circunstancias y además me había roto un
pie
la primera todos sabíamos de mi hermano
pequeño al que adoraba llamaba y me
costaba mucho remontar esto
las siguientes que habíamos montón a
estar está bien hecho de guiones y de
tonterías voy a hacer una startup que
ahora es eso es lo que toca hicimos un
estudio de apps empezamos a rodar se nos
fue bien nos invirtieron unos americanos
sueño americano nos vamos a texas y de
repente se pasa de moda lo de las apps y
tenemos que cerrar y cuando cierras una
empresa de eeuu pierdes el visado de
trabajo y te tienes que largar entonces
al final de este periodo me despido de
mis hijas y mi mujer y yo me quedo a
desmontar la vida a vender la furgo los
muebles la televisión liquidar la
sociedad cerrar cerrar las cuentas del
banco que es un poco como los
documentales del serengueti cuando muere
un you y deja de repente el guepardo
luego llega la hiena luego el buitre y
de repente ves que tu vida boom es una
carcasa que no queda nada yo estaba ahí
solo un día cuando esto había pasado y
tenía un colchón seis cervezas en la
nevera y una muleta
qué pasa no queda nada de esa grasa
ostras tamborrada porque carla al
servidor y vuelvo a casa sin nada no
tengo no es que no tengo trabajo es que
no tengo profesión porque claro he hecho
tantas cosas
tal nadie se va a querer que no sé no sé
no sé por dónde empezar con este mantra
no tengo nada vuelvo con las manos
vacías vuelvo con las manos vacías y ahí
me asalta de repente un verso un verso
de un poema muy conocido que ataca de
kavafis y está acá es volver volver al
origen es volver a tu casa a tu lugar en
el mundo dice cuando emprende el viaje
hacia ítaca pide que el viaje sea largo
que sea rico en experiencias y termina
diciendo bueno y está acá es pobre no
tiene nada que darte es un pedregal no
hay nada pesos y cuando llegue será sabe
ya habrá salas rico en experiencias
pensé de repente hay un principio de
consuelo nuestras ricas experiencias el
consuelo es pariente del autoengaño lo
sabemos pero en españa hay una es otra
manera una frase muy simpática que es
que te quiten lo bailao
a todo el mundo que le sale mal las
cosas que te quiten lo bailao luego en
el cine en el cine hay nadie lo dijo
mejor que bogart que le dice ingrid
bergman lo de siempre nos quedará país
que está mal traducido no siempre nos es
willow esas clases siempre tendremos
países que no es lo mismo lo que te
queda es lo que aún no te han quitado
que lo que tienes lo que tienes para
siempre entonces pienso juegue claro las
experiencias y cuando se han pasado que
son las experiencias pues las expertas
son tus historias en el momento en que
las repertorio siempre está ahí es lo
que te cuentas para explicar quién eres
para decírselo a alguien para entenderte
y de repente ahora la segunda cerveza en
esta mañana hacia pienso que
experiencias que cuáles son en qué
momento mi vida tenía sentido estaba
colmada trufa
me gustaba vivirla y de repente aparece
ahí y esto es un hallazgo que hice en
ese momento una carpetita en la memoria
se llaman las primeras veces
en las primeras veces en las primeras
veces la vida estaba llena de algo que
merecía la pena vivirla y de repente
pienso en el primer beso me acuerdo una
italiana en un campamento llega de ella
me sonreía se no te voy a golpear en la
vida te tengo que besar y como se besa
uno viendo películas porque tras
proyectos la historia de un primer beso
en todos personajes lo que john wayne a
zona cosas y de este tío sabe la serie
las sillas de pies otra otra otra
primera vez poemas me gusta la
posibilidad va un colegio al que llegue
nuevo y una profesora fe antipática que
éste me va a catear me voy a septiembre
seguro y de repente se ponen un poema de
un felipe y me quedo a la poesía no era
sólo hacer rimas de algo más vale que te
estalló en la cabeza yo quiero hacer ese
líquido poder hacer eso con el lenguaje
y se convierte así una obsesión y
empieza a ser una lista una lista de
primeras veces las primeras veces las
compartiremos en el primer beso el
primer libro el primer viaje luego ya se
van volviendo más singulares más que
tienen que ver con la historia de cada
uno de nosotros como la primera vez hizo
un rodaballo a la brasa o que corrió un
maratón y luego ya están las
inconfesables inhabilitarían para ser
presidente esta comunidad
al día siguiente cojo cojo el vuelo para
españa' vuelvo y esto se convierte en
pensamiento obsesiva empieza a preguntar
primeras veces puedes probarlo en una
cena aburrida el primer beso el primer
polvo y todo porque ya ha pasado tanto
tiempo que es información que se puede
clasificar sin pudor
[Música]
en esto que se organiza mucho jolgorio
veréis que hasta el tío más aburrido
capta la atención todos vosotros con sus
primeras veces
y hay algunos y entonces ya me pongo a
desarrollarlas con esta idea que es una
idea que me ayuda a no enfrentarme a ese
bosque oscuro del que hago con mi vida
con 40 está la situación ya la madrid
y empiezo a escribir y al final se
convierte en un tocho que lo voy
haciendo circular y una editora un día
me dice oye esto es una novela vamos
vamos a publicar lo que yo había escrito
el sistema lo que yo quería hacer y de
repente tengo un libro publicado bueno y
entonces en esto de las primeras veces
que os digo que es muy divertido hacerlo
en equipo así en una cena a vuestros
abuelos vuestros padres que andes
conocisteis cuál fue nuestro primer eso
pero cuando lo haces solo y realmente
vas a ir al meollo
y claro tiene sus peligros no se puede
meter un pantano de nostalgia del que no
sale entonces no hay que entre las
primeras veces como como entras a
exhumar cadáveres en un cementerio sino
más bien como como un batallón de
rescate después de un terremoto buscando
supervivientes a las primeras veces hay
que mirarlas no por lo que se ha pagado
lo que está muerto en ellas sino por lo
que sigue latiendo y qué es lo que sigue
latiendo una promesa de felicidad porque
si os fijáis una promesa inextinguible a
la base os fijáis en el primer beso que
es el primer beso como porque hay besos
que fue en su terreno fue el primer beso
que colmó el primer libro que es como el
primer viaje que es cómo os hice una
promesa de que otro besos colmaría de
que otro libros con mariah de que habría
otro viaje que colmaría entonces
repetiste y vino la segunda y la tercera
así como lo es para que venga otra vez
otra vez hasta que perdiste la cuenta
y sus disputas son son cosas pequeñas
son cosas muy sencillas tan sencillas
que nos olvidamos de ellas sobre todo
cuando hemos llegado ahí ya sea el medio
del viaje de nuestras vidas de repente
te olvidas y son esas veces las que las
que contienen toda la historia de tu
camino de tu relación con las cosas que
merecen la pena en la vida el amor el
deseo el arte la exploración y cuando te
olvidas de eso entras en el bosque
oscuro pero para salir y que está muy
bien hacer la prueba exponerte al
relatar de las nuevas rescatar el deseo
no estés en el bosque oscuro da igual
ponte a relatar así la tarta a ti misma
narradas las primeras veces a
construirlas hasta que tengan peso como
barro cocido y después las vas poniendo
una silla al lado del otro como si fuera
adoquines y de repente el camino se
dibuja otra vez bajo tus pies cuando es
la última vez que habéis pensado en
vuestras primeras veces
gracias
[Aplausos]